be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so it all starts here and I'm
really excited to see to see what
Jonathan Hickman does with us this is
x-men vol 5 issue number 1 also known as
dawn of X and I am very excited about
this opposed you guys who are a little
confused about this here's an important
thing to understand volumes and comic
books are a weird thing right like
technically volume denotes an entire run
but it's like volumes within a volume
right so you have like the overarching
volume which is this is however many
iterations of this comic we've had
technically we've had five iterations or
five relaunches of the x-men comic the
first one was Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
that was the original x-men run that was
canceled the second one was x-men vol 2
volume 2 issue number 1 which came in 91
and then there were a whole bunch of
others after that and we're currently on
five
he had like all-new all-different marvel
you had the post heroes reborn you had
the the post house of M the heroic age
you had like all kinds of different
relaunches over the years of Marvel
that's why this is volume 5 within vol 5
you'll have the first however many
issues make up the first story arc which
would be like volume 1 so it'll be x-men
vol 5 volume 1 I know it's kind of weird
it's a little strange but nonetheless
this picks up with an attack on Orcas
see this is why I say you have to read
Jonathan Hickman from beginning to the
end
right because Hickman is reckoning he's
not gonna do house of X and then powers
of X and then treat dawn of X like it's
a whole new relaunch know the relaunch
came with a pre loot right so you just
kind of keep on reading as if
everything's just kind of always been
but the attack on Orcas is actually kind
of interesting here because it's not the
x-men launching an attack in the
traditional sense like oh my god there's
humans here we have to get them it's the
x-men launching like a really more of
like a rescue a rescue mission than
anything else but I really like the way
that Hickman is doing this right because
he depicts the x-men as we're going in
there to achieve a mission nestled the
council calls for whatever happens
happens I like the brazen nature of the
x-men now right because up until this
point and this is one of the things that
I wasn't a huge fan of up into this
point really coming after all-new
all-different marvel the x-men always
kind of seem like a team that was on the
defensive right like we like they're
always backing off they're always you
know retreating or something along those
lines they're never really like
launching an attack against someone like
making the first move and I like this
you know they actually are kind of going
in and they're doing their thing it's
very much a throwback to the old-school
x-men comics I know I sound like a
common book hipster but I usually I do
kind of like to throw back to the whole
thing of course now the mission is led
by storm and Cyclops and this is no
accident when it comes to this like when
Hickman Rutledge would really put
together the council and you have
storming in Cyclops leading field
missions
hickman chose us for a reason right
because there's a lot of history here
storm and Cyclops are kind of like the
one-two punch when it comes to leading
the x-men team right Cyclops was a field
commander for a long long time until
after the events of the Phoenix and Dark
Phoenix saga is when he left and then
store and became the new leader of the
team after she battled Cyclops for that
role and she won and so as a result of
that storm led the led the x-men team
while Cyclops led x-factor and then once
the two teams merged back into a single
unit again you got x-men golden x-men
Blue Cyclops led one team storm led the
other so it makes sense that like
Hickman's sort of bringing all that
history in and giving us these two
characters who were going out and and
doing their own thing
the other big thing about this is the
arrival of Magneto now here's the thing
man Pikmin does an amazing job of riding
villains I think Hickman writes villains
better than he writes heroes like
believe it or not go back and look at
his publishing history and it's like the
villains are almost always written
better than the heroes and that's what I
love about the way that that magneto has
done here because in the last five years
or so Magneto's almost kind of been like
a background character Cyclops sort of
took on the role that used to belong to
magneto by light it's kind of
militaristic we'll do whatever we need
to do to win kind of situation and it
was cool to see the evolution of his
character to see him go from like the
x-men Boy Scouts to Casting Xavier out
of his own team after house of am taking
the x-men over saying I'm the one
running the show now falling more in
line with magneto is used but then you
know kind of fell more to the to the
background and to see magneto kind of
brought to the forefront again and
really kind of drawn and depicted in
this way where he's like this imposing
figure like crap magneto is here like I
like seeing that like I like I love
seeing that depiction cuz it's just like
you're talking about this insanely
powerful mutant right I think in a lot
of ways people sleep on just how
powerful magneto is and I feel like
before this all really comes to an end
before Hickman's run-ins we're gonna see
magneto shine in spectacular fashion to
say nothing of that suit magneto looks
like a boss in that white silver suit
dude it looks legit but nonetheless you
know it's it's cool to kind of see him
arrive here because pilars like let's
take care of these humans and it's like
no no no we're here for a mission we're
here to achieve a mission for the
council now this is a big deal and this
is a very important thing to take note
of because what this shows is that at
the end of the day magneto really does
fall in line with the ideology that
they're ensuing right because one of the
things he says here is like there was a
time when I would have just taken all
these humans out right like I would have
just eradicated them all and it's not a
matter of annihilating humanity it's a
matter of achieving that goal
there and that's one of the big
differences back in the day back in like
the 80s and 90s magneto was just taking
him out and that would have been immune
to that right he would have just melted
these guys and there were you know just
kind of destroyed him and that would
have been the end of them but to see him
in a position now where he's just sort
of like we're here to achieve a
particular goal it's awesome to kind of
see that progression but with them
showing up here were the x-men arriving
here that's what we end up realizing the
reason why they're here is because what
they're doing is rescuing all these
various mutants but one of these mutants
stands out and when the system more or
less opens up rather this this kind of
you know cocooned stasis pod whatever it
is opens up and this mutant pours out
then the initial analysis is well
they're they're not really human but
they're not really mutant to kind of
post human but somebody's going on here
with regards to time now if you're not
familiar with Hickman riding if you're
not familiar with the stuff he's done in
the past year just kind of be like what
in the world is going on here but if you
read The Ultimate Universe if you read
Ultimates by Jonathan Hickman that's a
child of the vault and it's just like
wow dude I can't believe you brought him
back like I can't believe your brother
he's bringing back children of the vault
I think that's what it looks like but
the only other thing I can assume here
is that it's the black vault or
something else going on there but I
don't think it's black vault like
literally they say like like some kind
of like temporal anomaly temporal energy
is coming off this girl now those you
guys who don't know children of the
vault Judy was so cool this was a
concept I've got the videos down in the
description so you guys can go watch
those but the children of the vault was
this concept created by Reed Richards in
the Ultimate Universe and what he did
was create this place called city this
great big huge Citadel and what did up
happening here is that within the
confines of city time passed differently
and so what Reed could do is he could
basically create life and then watch it
grow over the course of however long and
it was something like 6000 years passed
within the span of like a few days or
something along those lines but
basically he created like post-humans
right people who evolved beyond normal
humans and this is awesome because what
it means is the plot thickens because
now not only do we have to deal with
Omega signals we have all the stuff that
we saw with regards to like the Nimrods
and all those things going on in house
and powers of X now we've got post
humans making their return and this is
awesome because post humans are
basically super humans it's awesome to
see hitmen bring it back the downside of
this is this child of the vault
immediately teleports out she's just
like I gotta go like we got we gotta
bounce out of here keep that in the back
of your head do not forget that that
will become important later on I promise
you that will become insanely important
later on do not forget that please for
the love of God do not forget that it
will become important later on but
nonetheless once they get back to krakoa
it's kind
interesting there because storm is worth
more or less been running on fumes since
she's been here grabbing these mutants
that were held inside the hob and
bringing them back to this location it's
fine for what it is right because it's
kind of like hey they're gonna get some
medical treatment and they're all gonna
be okay everything's gonna be fine
remember cacoa is a totally
self-contained ecosystem right so
they've got telepath to deal with like
any sort of mental anguish they've been
through Kurkova itself creates various
medicines and things they can use in
order to heal themselves or you know
recover from from whatever they're
struggling from but in following that
you've also got the return of Magneto
now notice this when magneto arrives
here he's almost perceived as like a
savior of sorts and this is really
Hickman tying into the history of
magneto right like on the surface you
would look at and say well magneto dude
this guy's a jerk man he's a glory hog
but just everyone I freed you all me
alone by myself I did it it's like okay
magneto get a little carried away with
yourself but in enough magneto has
always been viewed in a lot of ways by
the mutant population as kind of a
mutant Messiah s character not in so far
as they would follow him into oblivion
right I mean he doesn't always have
everybody on his side but the perception
of Magneto and the way in which he
operates is he's not really a bad guy
magneto was a guy who was just kind of
like I'm doing what's best for Newton
khand
I'll take the heavy-handed approaches I
need to right but like first and
forefront isn't meeting population he's
a champion of youth right and where
Xavier was more of a half-measure more
of like well let's see if we can't talk
to them let's see if we can't reason
with them and you know if we can get
them to listen like magneto was like no
you can't either so like either they can
listen or they can be made to listen but
years are gonna be listen to what it is
we have to say it's been nature of
things right like violence is not always
the answer but it is a answer and it's a
very effective answer right magneto got
stuff done and it's a cool thing about
his character and so him showing up here
people are kind of like but what if they
come back and the response of Magneto
it's the most boss response ever he says
let man run from me do magneto is a boss
I love the way he's written in this is
absolutely amazing but it's a cool thing
here because what you end up doing is
you end up having Scott Summers who
basically travels travels out to meet up
with the rest of his family but before
we do
we've got Jonathan Hickman establishing
in a lot of ways the current status quo
of things we're just to say the new
villain who's on the scene and this is a
guy named director Dava now director
Davo is the one who really sort of
spearheaded this whole orcas orcas
system right at least that seems to be
the case he's the one
together all these various scientists
from like shield and armor and and
hammer and Hydra and so on and so forth
all for the purpose of trying to find a
way to basically contain and control the
mutant threat right so it's almost like
a reworked version of project wide-awake
for those of you guys who never read
comics back in like that back in the 80s
and 90s which technically I wasn't
really alive at that point but I
wouldn't read them anyway for those you
guys who weren't really reading when the
events of the original project wide
awake were happening it wasn't really
like a one-shot it was just like like a
page here three or four pages there you
know it was just kind of spread all over
the place and when you go back and you
read it you read like the entirety of
Chris Claremont run you get this great
big huge cohesive concept that we call
Project wide awake this was very similar
to that in terms of how this is being
done and how it's being depicted you get
a couple pages here and then you move on
right that's that's kind of how this
whole thing this whole thing sort of
unfolded in the old Claremont stories
and it's cool to see that method of
storytelling kind being it kind of being
maintained here but the idea is that
this guy director Dava is the one who's
basically like hey look this is the
entire like creation of mother mold all
that kind of stuff that's all me and is
one of these things where he sort of
ignores what it is that Kareem is
telling him I remember Kareena is an
omega Sentinel she's basically a more
machine than she is human but the idea
behind this is she's like what you were
doing was going to spark a response you
had to know that you had to know that
like creating a signal that created the
creative master molds which in turn
would create other signals you had to
know the x-men were going to respond to
that you instigated a scenario where the
x-men were guaranteed to respond and
when they did they ended up killing a
handful of people who worked for you and
the responsive director damo is yes but
that's the step that needs to be taken
I'm doing the right thing I'm fighting
on bisa on behalf of humanity notice
this it's kind of an extreme perspective
but it exists opposed to Magneto's views
right where magneto is steadfast
protecting mutant kind this guy director
Davila like so many films before him is
steadfast protecting humanity and this
is cool this is an interesting idea
because what he does is he basically
says like the fall of the fall of like
mother mold that's nothing like we have
a whole host of things that are working
in the background a whole host of things
that we want to get done from here and
so it was cool because what it says is
what we saw in house of powers of X
that's not the end of it it's nowhere
near the end of it it's a very small
thing now at this point we transition
over to out to Scott Summers along with
like pretty much his full family you
also get Gabriel summers here now here's
an important thing to understand
Gabriel summers died during and in the
aftermath of war of contra he's been
well he wasn't really killed he was kind
of yanked away into like a black hole
more or less some kind of gravity well
blackbolt ended up coming back we never
found out what happened to Gabriel we
never found out what happened to Vulcan
he was just gone
now a lot of that was part of the lead
up to secret worst and so Marvel I
imagine if it was just kind of a thing
where I was like well they're more or
less gone don't really worry about
explaining it just kind of leave it the
way it is and then whatever happens
happens but kind of seems to have been a
lot of the response with what was going
on there and so this is really like the
first real time we're seeing Vulcan
after the events of seeker wars and
all-new all-different marvel but he's a
good guy here right there's no semblance
of like I hate my brothers and I'm a bad
guy and I I conquered the Shiar Empire
and I'm going to war with the creeks
like we don't really see any of that
going on here and there doesn't really
seem to be any reference to it it's just
kind of a thing that's there so I think
Hickman's just sort of rolling with it
and just kind of saying hey if he never
really read anything about Vulcan before
don't worry about it just know that he's
really powerful he can control all forms
of energy and he's Omega level and and
that's really it it's cool but like
that's pretty much it and this is
interesting to see and it works and not
only that you have these small things to
go on for example like you literally got
cable hanging out with rosin and of
course Raza is like the weapons guy he's
almost kinda like the gunsmith so to
speak of the of the starjammers group
and it's interesting to see because like
he's got like this these super advanced
weapons and cables like little kid
cables like freaking out like I've got
to see that you know and so on and so
forth who the guys who aren't really
familiar with what's going on here let
me backpedal a little bit let me offer
some explanation so so when it comes to
the starjammers this is an idea
introduced way back during Chris
Claremont run and what he did is he said
initially it was believed that Cyclops
and his brother were thrown out of a
plane given parachutes and they landed
you know more or less safely after their
plane crashed after their plane went
down Clermont came back in and changed
some of that and said actually the Shiar
abducted his mother and his father and
they were just kind of taken out into
space and eventually his mom died and an
in Corsair
who is a leader to start a leader of the
starjammers formed the starjammers as
was essentially a pirate group out there
why there space pirates right so think
of them as like a pirate version of the
guardians of the galaxy for what you've
seen in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
a lot of ways because of that they're
pretty capable but these are the members
that you're basically seeing here right
Raza and and and Hepzibah
you know you're seeing like chode you're
seeing a lot of these characters here
who are just part of the starjammers
group and the reason why they're here is
there are a lot of there's a lot of
history there right the starjammers are
like extended family for Scott Summers
right Corsair is is biological dad and
then the starjammers are part of the
team so let's take a cyclops brought his
own x-men you want to this kind of
family thing there's been a lot of
history these teams have fought side by
side with each other there's a lot of
closeness that goes on between these
guys with regards to cable being a kid
this was covered in the the new x-force
run that I think was written by Greg Pak
although I'm not gonna swear to it but
the idea is that you had cable who's
been around for a long long time I like
the adult version of cable because of
the fact that he's gone back in time and
measured the time stream so much his
younger counterpart killed him he was
just like you've been screwing up time
consistently since you've been alive
right you just you're a walking wreck
Comus you like the x-men or like hey we
want to do something where the Avengers
want to do something and then here comes
cable Gemini have a crack in the ground
go do that guys you're gonna screw up
the time Street you're kind of a hassle
so basically like his younger self ended
up killing him off and it was a way for
Marvel anyway to kind of remove the idea
that cables just sort of gonna fix
everything all the time and so that's
that's why I Junger part is younger
counterpart it's currently here now we
also talked about that in the return of
Cyclops right when Cyclops is
resurrected we cover that as well so you
guys are welcome to go check that out
but there's some cool discussion that
goes on now one of the important things
that really takes place here is Corsair
starts talking to Cyclops and he says
look man I can't agree with everything
that you're doing here it's cool that
you guys have formed your own island
nation but you have to understand
humanity is coming from the perspective
of fear and so what you've basically
done here is you've created in an ion
you've created a nation-state unto
yourself and then you've gathered every
single person that humanity is afraid of
into a singular location as far as
humanity is concerned you're making war
preparations it's the you know you could
be doing anything you could be gathering
all these mutants together and then
training them to become like you know
military capable and they're gonna send
them out into the world and conquer
humanity you can be training them to
become humanitarians so they're gonna go
out and they're gonna heal the world but
because Humanity is governed by fear in
this regard they're gonna deviate to the
worst-case scenario so yes it's cool
that you're doing that but you might
also be creating more problems than you
are benefits at the end of the day those
cyclopses response is we'll deal with a
threat as it comes for right now we're
doing the right thing we're protecting
our kind as best we can so is one of
these things worse like what the x-men
are doing on earth has not gone
unnoticed
across the entirety of the universe and
it makes sense right because some of the
most powerful people are on earth and so
earth is constantly monitored by all
these various extraterrestrial races
because who in the heck knows when
things are gonna pop off right so as a
result of this what we end up doing is
waiting up jumping back to the Orcas
space and we end up having this
conversation that takes place with
director Dava and one of the things
about this is that Killians wife
remember she was there she was a
scientist who was on board one of the
vessels when killing himself was
destroyed the responsive Davo is you
know like world war
about that he's like yes um this is my
fault but at the end of the day we're
doing the right thing this this chick is
just kind of like hey look I'm not too
worried about that because we can bring
my husband back now this is a very easy
thing to overlook because it's like okay
so like whatever she can't bring her
husband back that's not to take away
from this who cares if her husband comes
back nobody cares if Killian comes back
what matters about this is that if she
can resurrect her husband she can
resurrect anybody else and that means
that we can see the return of all of our
trash we can see the return of like
almost any of these characters out there
who have or could possibly continue to
be major threats against the mutant
population right so like William Stryker
leaving the purifiers different things
like that like imagine if that was the
case right you had you have the
purifiers of William Stryker basically
this crazy religious fundamentalists you
know evangelical group who thinks God
wants them to kill mutants and they're
backed by like some of the best science
and technology in the Marvel Universe
right like they have all this money and
all those technology backing them who
knows what kind of strikes they could
launch against against all of all of you
and cons and so it's it's cool to see
there's a lot of possibilities that can
come out of this and that's why things
like this are so important is because
it's not the immediate statement that's
made by virtue of I can resurrect my
husband it's all the possibilities that
can come out of it all the things that
can come later on down the line because
that's the nature of Jonathan Hickman
writing with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to commerce explain it make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rod war if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]